I'm joined by talk to these
International Isabella talk to your
presenter Richard Tice and campaign
related the true and fair party Gina
Miller well welcome to all of you
Superstar pack if ever there was one uh
Gina so I want to start with you because
Dominic Robb his future hangs in the
balance uh this report into whether he's
a big bully has gone to number 10 where
she seemed like has spent hours going
through it no decision or announcement
based on what he's been reading today so
we expect it tomorrow you yourself had
experience with Rob which makes you
think he is a bully well they they're
two different things I've had personal
experience where he was a bully to me
but this is in what way in so I was um
doing uh a morning today program about
um the case that I wrote my first case
and in coming down from the show in the
lift he basically called me names
um like what like
um it can't work out if you're just a
silly [__] or um if you are really rich
or if you've got or you're just naive he
called you a silly [__] or if I was
naive Dominique wrong called you a silly
[__]
but after that as well when we next met
another occasion when we were on um we
were going to another question time show
whatever and you know he then his
behavior was inappropriate as well on
that occasion in my way and I've written
so I was on the show I was going to be
there with Nish Kumar the comedian who
was on my brother was there and and RAB
sort of went up to my brother who looks
nothing like Niche and said to him oh
we're on together and totally ignored me
and said we're on the show together this
evening my brother said no I'm not
um you know we don't look all the same
and RAB sort of looked really
embarrassed and nishikma came out and he
said well why didn't you say hello to
Gina Miller you're on the show she's on
the panel with us tonight and he just
looked at me and walked off and it was
just a bizarre way of Behaving I mean
that's sort of weird inappropriate the
first thing he said yeah if Dominic Rob
who's Deputy Prime Minister called you a
sister well he wasn't that and obviously
he is now he wasn't he is now but but if
but I would I was going to say is it's
different is this Behavior that's going
on this this report is about him being a
boss across not one but three Department
government departments yeah but if
that's the way he spoke to a
high-profile woman at the time privately
when he doesn't think people are
watching but the thing is I think it's
because he saw me as being lesser than
himself yeah I think that's why okay
okay let me bring in Isabel because I
think you came here to be defensive of
it but when you hear that as a woman
what do you think it's not even as a
woman I'm just actually shocked so I
mean I've known Dominic Robb since 2010
since he first came in as a back bench
newly elected toy MP I have never found
him anything other than at the very
least civil I think he's a got a very
very strong work ethic he is a
workaholic I think he demands very high
standards of himself and the people who
work for him and I strongly suspect that
that results in him sometimes being
quite what do you feel now you've heard
he's quite demanding so I was absolutely
going to defend him on that basis if he
said that that is but you can also how
he wrote about me as well and talked
about me yeah but that particular line I
mean it's too tired should anyone be
Deputy Prime Minister who calls women
silly [__] I mean that is
indefensible that's obviously the first
I've heard of it truly shocking and one
would like to say frankly no I mean
that's just an extraordinary way to
carry on with anybody and what it makes
me think I've always looked at rather
just thought he always looks permanently
angry and has one of those mean faces
that's not enough to judge him or
convict him but otherwise none of it
surprises me I mean he looks cheerful
they've been a creepy kind of Hannibal
lecture way but for the but what what
Jesus just told me I can quite believe
that no it's because of my instinct
about it I can't believe anybody yes
it's because he didn't get it he was
angry he was yeah but he doesn't matter
it doesn't matter what it shows me
because what it shows me is he's
perfectly capable of doing that to you
but this is capable of any of these
things
say anything about it at the time I mean
that's quite a big story no no because I
was being battled though I was is being
attacked from just about everywhere for
the case the last thing I wanted to do
was bring more attention onto myself and
at the time I was so stunned when the
doors opened yeah um and uh you came out
the lifts I actually couldn't believe
somebody had actually just spoken to me
this was at the BBC yeah I was coming
down and left after the today program
what did you say to him I I didn't say
anything because my car came the the
runner came up and and sort of said your
car's here Mrs Miller and I went off
and in the way no no in the way and the
reason I know that is because I bought
this thing a weird habit I write things
down and so I actually have the diary
from wow the time where I wrote it down
have you ever talked about this before
well not not work but but also no I did
do an article in the independent they
checked and I they've got my they saw my
entry you didn't include that that
particular I said but I said that he not
that particular phrasing but I mean I
gotta say that that to me is a big
development because it shows to me he's
this is a guy who talks to women like
you like that that's pretty shocking
yeah I mean I want ministers to be
demanding of civil servants to get
performance so they're held to account
and they deliver for taxpayers who pay
their salaries but we do not want
ministers behaving like that frankly
with anybody but what I'm saying is this
is is this somebody who which plays into
what peers is saying is about this is
somebody who when it's Juniors or maybe
some people he doesn't see as being on
the same level as himself has a
sustained pattern of behavior it says to
me it's just a nasty piece of work and a
bullet which is bullying and so
therefore it makes me think that I mean
let's see what the report says but
there's so many people have there's so
similar stories it's like eventually you
know
can he really be an innocent guy when we
just said that well I think synack's got
a real problem because the thing is if
he if he says no um you know rap stays
there's a whole load of civil servants
who are saying that they're gonna walk
and they could bring individual cases
against raps so this is not over a long
way I think we should obviously see how
it all goes but it may be reconvene
afterwards maybe next week because it's
going to be a big story uh we've
actually run out of talking but this was
such a enthralling development